so this is this is an exciting thing i
for one
um i'm a huge fan of like everything to
do with space
and i'm pretty sure you know like you
probably
you're probably someone who just sat
there looking at the stars and thought
to yourself like man i'd like to be
there one day like this must be a bit of
a dream come true for you
yeah i i grew up and you know i was
always fascinated by
the stars and and sort of you know
space travel and history of like nasa
and all that kind of stuff and
um yeah it's been it's been
an amazing opportunity to get to play
one of the
one of the first people to ever go up
there you know
yeah and you know the original mercury
seven like
literally the first uh attempt
at getting up there that must have been
a thrill what did you learn
over the course of preparing for this
that you were surprised to know
uh well i mean quite a lot
um i came in very last minute i came in
four days before
shooting started so it was i didn't have
a huge amount of time
there but i didn't
fully i'd read the book before and i'd
seen the movie but you know i'd never
really thought
about the fact that these guys literally
sat on top of a nuclear rocket and were
willing to be
shut off into space when nobody had ever
been there before nobody had any idea
what was going to happen
um if the capsule could even survive it
if the person could survive it
so yeah i never even thought about that
side i never thought about that side of
things the mentality of what it must be
to be somebody who is willing to get you
know because these guys were all
test pilots and they were willing to get
into airplanes that nobody had ever
flown before and had to push them to the
limit
and then you know the majority of test
pilots never made it back so
it's a completely different completely
different mentality you know
yeah and the training is so intense um i
understand you guys didn't do the
centrifuge but did you do
any of the any of the crazy sort of uh
physical training that those guys would
have to do jake and i got to film
in the mastiff which is the thing that
sort of rotates
on all the different axises and you spin
around and all that kind of stuff so we
we actually did
shoot in that we didn't practice it um
but we
spent an entire day being long
angle that you can think of so that was
a lot of fun
and uh how did you feel at the end of
that day i was actually
i i really enjoyed it i could have kept
going and normally i'm uh
well i'm okay on roller coasters and
stuff but i was uh
i was thrilled yeah i wanted to do this
i wanted to do that but
i think i probably would have passed out
i'd say
were you like one of those kids that
dreamt of becoming an astronaut that saw
that one this is this is something i got
to do
i don't know if i dreamt of becoming an
astronaut i was always
you know i always wondered what it would
be like to to go into space or
you know that kind of thing but i don't
know if i
not really no i dreamt of being a rock
star or
something like probably but yeah you
know
but it's funny because in a way these
guys were you guys were like rock stars
being the first to do it yeah they they
became
you know essentially the most famous
people on the planet uh
and basically they were even bigger than
rock stars you know the only people who
had fame like that were
movie stars at the time and maybe
royalty but these guys became world
famous and that's part of
you know we take for granted everybody
has a phone everybody
can have an instagram account or
whatever and set up and have whatever
millions of men
people but you know it wasn't like that
back then
and so these guys had a level of fame
that was
just you know inexplicable you couldn't
even fathom it
and that's part of what i think the
series
you know navigates really well is how
does that affect
them but how does it affect a family
you know um how does it affect
them within their family and how they
relate to their
wife and kids and stuff which i think is
is
really important thing that this version
of the right stuff
um you know kind of looks into
speaking of one of the most famous
people in the world leo dicaprio was
producer on this
did you have any uh any experience with
him was he very hands-on in this project
um uh i didn't have an awful lot of
experience with him
and i waved at him once in the office uh
but and we've emailed um but
you know so it was sort of we were in
florida so
we were shooting over there and it was
you know the the way that a tv show
works is this
you know a lot of producers and there's
different writers and
show runner and all that kind of stuff
and directors so there's like a huge
maze of people to navigate um but um i
hope he's uh
i hope he's very proud of it i hope he's
happy with it i like how you just said
oh i waved that
in the office for most people that would
be like the moment of their life
that would be that would be the slo-mo
moment that they replay it over and over
again
yeah well that was actually that was a
few years ago i had a meeting in the
office that was a few years ago that
wasn't even on this but
i didn't i waved at leonardo's capital
now would you go to space as a
you know not even as an astronaut as a
regular person you know spacex is going
to be doing those trips up there is that
something that you
have thought like maybe i could do this
i think i would like to yeah i'm
i definitely would not like to have done
it in 1959 or 1960
but i think maybe now i would uh
i'd consider it it's one of those ones
that i say oh yeah i'd love to do that
but i'd imagine when you're sitting
on top of whatever hundreds of tons
of liquid nitrogen or whatever it is
that they use
and i'd say you might begin to think
twice you know
you